[Applause]
[Music]
new releases is back from hiatus you
might even say it just stepped out of
the hyperbolic time chamber but this
first episode of the new year has more
than just Dragon Ball Z although there's
definitely a lot of anime influenced
it's been a while so let's shake off the
rust and check out some of the biggest
games launching this week
first up here's DBZ as the Kakarot name
implies this open-world RPG tells Goku's
story but he's not the only playable
character you can also throw down with
Gohan piccolo and even fusion forms like
Vegeta additionally series creator Akira
Toriyama made a new Ginyu Force member
and her name is bond you Kakarot covers
that arc plus the cell saga filler
episodes and more you can relive those
adventures on ps4 Xbox one and PC on
Friday the 17th you can also do battle
in outer space with super mega space
blaster special turbo this mouthful of a
game is a shoot-'em-up with bullet-hell
elements aka you're a spaceship battling
other spaceships and dodging lasers and
bullets there are 15 different ships to
unlock and various power-ups to grab to
make your fight easier and you can do it
all in co-op or competitive multiplayer
to space blaster comes to ps4 Xbox one
PC and switch on Tuesday the 14th that
same day you can play through red bow in
a quick few hours this short story
driven game puts you in control of a
young girl named ro who's stuck in a
nightmare you'll have to solve puzzles
to escape the darkness and you can do so
on ps4 Vita xbox one and switch on the
14 it's also headed to PC on Friday the
17th just be warned that red bows
creator does specifically say the game
covers some sensitive topics
let's brighten the mood a bit the switch
is getting a rather puzzling release
this week but in a good way puzzle and
Dragons gold is the latest in the super
popular puzzle fighting series and the
first on switch battles start simple you
match three orbs of the same color to
make your monster attack your opponents
but then they get deeper with special
skills and monster lineups that lands on
Wednesday the 15th and I already know
which monsters I'm gonna send to the
frontlines switch has one more big game
coming this week with Tokyo Mirage
sessions sharp Fe encore this is an
enhanced version of the Wii U original
an RPG that combines the gameplay of
Shin Megami Tensei and Fire Emblem
turn-based battles use both SM T's
elemental weaknesses and fire emblems
weapon triangle as you progress through
each chapter you'll travel between
modern-day Tokyo and an alternate
dimension where the evil mirages come
from you can start dimension-hopping on
Friday the 17th and those are some of
the hottest games launching this week as
always remember that release dates are
based on retailer listings and are
subject to change thanks for watching
guys I'm back for 2020 and we'll have
another batch of January video games
next Sunday